OK.
This is a great voice mail follow up.
This is a voice mail in Spanish.
I will translate it for you.
It is all about my phone call last week with
a caller claiming to be named Pedro, claiming
to be from the country of Colombia.
And clearly he is not.
Take a listen to this.
I will translate.
Don't worry.
Delightful voicemail.
I love I want to.
I love the decline of the show as the segment
on that, but a thing like I. I'm a fan and
I'll get the.
There's the symbol, a stand up.
It's advocacy that gives the Columbia, he
says, in a way that gets people happy.
But this is a complete solution.
He said key though, though, in English, you
don't know that people get to keep their mouths
if they keep them away.
You must sort of get us to that point.
Yes.
Okay.
A person thinks that is politically die like
a suspended economy.
He thought, OK, so what the person is saying
is, first of all, that Pedro obviously has
a real or fake Mexican accent.
He doesn't sound at all like he's from Colombia.
But this was a big misunderstanding.
People thought that I referred to the capital
of Colombia as Quito, but at that I mispronounced
it.
Quito.
That's not what I did.
There's a part of Colombia called keep door
Q:You I BDO with an accent over the oh, it's
obscure and only people from Colombia would
know about it.
So my thought was to bring it up to trick
him and he seemed to say yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the capital.
So I know that Quito is not the capital of
Colombia.
I mentioned KEIB though, which is a region
or part of Colombia that seemed to really
perplex Pedro.
In any case, we love Pedro.
And hopefully he'll call back someday.
Do me a favor.
Take a three question 22nd survey at David
Pakman dot com slash survey.
We are asking our audience how affected you
are by Corona virus.
It takes just 20 seconds David Pakman dot
com slash survey.
I think the results will be interesting.
Totally anonymous.
We will see you on today's bonus show.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.